let me ask you this there's a rumor
going around
that the lakers are looking into ben
simmons
if you're the lakers gm hypothetically
iman jumper you're the gm we've seen it
happen james jones is the sun's gm he
was in the league not long too long ago
if you could trade russell westbrook for
ben simmons would you make that swap
if i'm the lakers if you're the lakers
you're making this one
that's fair for sure
but that's just me
that's my preference basketball
it's it it helps you a lot on on the
defensive liability that's happening you
got the best perimeter defensive guy in
the in the league becomes great on
defense yeah
it ruins a lot offensively it does it
scares them it scares them but it only
ruins a lot offensively if you're not
willing to take the challenge of what
the challenge is when taking on ben
simmons
the challenge of taking on ben simmons
is
he doesn't shoot threes
but it's not the
we need him to
he just doesn't shoot threes and it's
okay
the moment everybody gets that [ __ ] out
of their mind he's gonna be fine
who gives a [ __ ]
demar don't shoot threes
listen don't fool yourself for what ben
simmons has been out here
i think he's been the best defensive
player of the last three or four years
[ __ ] the defense bro offensively he's a
bit of a liability though no he's not he
just doesn't shoot the three you know if
he creates
something if he was six foot two y'all
would not care that he can't shoot
if he was six two
because he's six eight
and he light skin
y'all got an issue with this man
are you saying he looks like a tall
steph curry no yes yeah
that's precisely what i'm saying
that's literally what i'm telling y'all
bro
literally
if this dude was just dark-skinned i
don't think we would care but he is
supposed technically he's supposed to be
able to shoot the three and if i was a
coach i would not give a [ __ ] if this
boy shook a three i can't believe he got
this far without shooting the three
i wish i could have got that far without
shooting the three bro right right i
wish to death that coaches never turned
me to three and d i hate shooting threes
i've always hated it never liked it felt
like it was soft made me look soft made
me feel soft i didn't feel tough when i
had to shoot hella threes and people was
like why are you well you gotta go back
to that mode i'm like bro they took the
ball from me i stand in the corner i
feel light skin i feel like the sun is
not hitting me at all
like that's how i felt you know what i'm
saying i feel like i'm losing my
superpowers standing over here is just
not the same and i feel like
if the lakers take on being simmons it's
like sweaty if you let that man run
point he pushing that tempo
all game now you got him and braun going
back and forth both of them point
forwards you're changing the game that's
twin towers at the pg
we've never seen that
yeah i just think i think ads gotta i
don't know and then you got a d yeah
give me two shooters and let's go hoot
yeah
what the [ __ ] they just need the
shooters what the [ __ ] is the other side
gonna do they just need the questions
but yeah i would pull the trigger on
that no disrespect and then you would
sign yourself to be a shooter no
disrespect god you know how i get down
with you sweaty go to war with you
against you or whatever man there's no
disrespect to you but if i'm being a gm
boy
i'm getting that ring kid